you know no no no I really don't like
that I'm ready to prove my love I feel
like I didn't I didn't prove it enough
at the wedding no she didn't the vows
were not enough I might have a chance to
prove that my devotion goes deeper and
further than yours
I'm usually competitive in general so
like just racing down the hall he
tripped me to get to the door that's not
true commander so I guess this answers
your question right now I think I'm
gonna like go the extra mile cuz your
competin you're gonna let go an extra
foot okay bye
I'll miss you good luck she's adorable
she's so nervous and she looked good
though oh she looks so pretty she's
gonna say clothes on the floor she just
doesn't pick up her clothes she like
takes them off and puts them on the
ground
JP likes to talk a lot which is amazing
but sometimes it's just like Shh she
doesn't leave the house after 9 p.m. I'm
tired from cleaning up after you 10 is
afraid of witches I am he doesn't like
them don't anything that slithers she
creeps that okay lunatics on the street
or just like stuff you see in the news
or whatever muscled scares spiders she's
definitely afraid of spiders you know so
it's for the other one you can use
whatever you want except the mayonnaise
and the dressing all right so this
smells like trash smells like fish you
grabbed so many this is pickled pig skin
well a crunch in there I mean these are
all some of my favorite things together
so far it's giving you some fun things
here's a little drop of clam juice
here's some Mayo I see your clam juice
and I raise you
gefilte fish juice I just realized I put
shrimp and milk in here I don't know
what if we like accidentally created
like a really good hangover cure that's
good and that's good uh-huh what is just
getting warmer it's that once I forgot
your shoes I love you
I got it's so crunchy how's that Oh Oh
God not good I love you but I'm not
gonna kiss you right now no okay no I'll
tell you what man these dudes probably
got some cousins back home and I don't
mark them so we already got you're not
winning this oh my god oh my god I had
four where's the other did hell did I
held it nah man I'll take an elf it is
oh I will do that will you do it I'm not
looking I'm a little scared of Harriette
it kind of feels nice put on my back I'm
startled here I'm not startling hair you
hairy starting at me I'm not gonna yes
you are there you go she can sense the
fear okay I love you so much that is
good Wow I don't think I would do any of
those things for anybody except for you
oh we got through it it's an awesome
story it was a fun experience I did
those things just just to prove to you
that there's not much that I wouldn't do
for you
[Music]